hello party people looking to Australian
commentaries for the film cata air Thank
You I'm thinking for that con air
appropriate guitar lick I'm Spencer J
Gilbert we should do a like Connor
criminal names I'm Spencer ice pick
Gilbert oh yes your lawn lawn the
slammer Harris and Dan the Mad Men
merle-jo the Beast star Danielle Laser
Puma Radford Wow
couldn't join us today there's a guy
they all have individual excuses I don't
know why they wouldn't want to be here
to talk about calm which we had John
Cusack to let walk us through their
excuses for wait now that's that's going
yeah counts of arson if you guys haven't
seen this show before we're talking
about the other show honors trailers for
Conair and we'll give you some of our
thought process is we were writing it
some things didn't make the Cayenne
literally some things didn't make the
cuts if you stick around to the end
there's some deleted scenes okay there's
actually some good ones this time we had
a lot we had a list there's so much to
say about Conair a lovely film honestly
like if you're [ __ ] on Connor what's
wrong with you like what do you have
against this movie that the movie
doesn't have against itself or know
exactly what's wrong with it
it's Connor does that thing where it is
it's anything to make it more fun
anything for a laugh anything that will
lead to like a fun action scene anything
that'll extend an action scene for a
little bit Cyrus the virus dies about 12
different sheriff's cuz every time they
would come up with a way to kill or
maybe like should we do that one like
yeah put them all in there he's got like
a Rasputin's
and he's dead he gets stabbed through
the leg he's on the they're fighting on
I believe a fire truck you can get
stabbed through the leg he gets like you
know so we think it's wood thrown into a
Construction Yard throw through two
windows on a conveyor belt that they
like that's running at night in Vegas
electrocuted in the power line yeah
and it's raining again and then on to
the head smashes right so I'm gonna
convey about that lifts him up and then
drops him and then there's a piece of
construction equipment that's doing
nothing it's just slamming the grave
someone could recut that - like the
george gershwin like that out of that
music appreciated but more broadly yacon
air is just pure fun injected right in
your hands and then it's just it's not
taking yourself seriously it's not
trying to like be like intricately
plotted like that's another like today
this movie would be like there'd be like
eight stops they have to make and
there'd be like all kinds of convolution
oh it's very clear what I find is just
go it would land what's fascinating
about this film to me is that this
sounds like a made-up premise to an
action movie and it sort of is but also
there really is a Conair there is an
airline or like an air service when they
need to transport criminals it's like a
prison bus like there are flights that
are full of criminals I imagine they're
not quite the same as this one maybe
they have some armed guard well I guess
not armed guards in kind of a gonna play
he's caught a real oh my god but the
screenwriter did say he went on a couple
flights on Con Air yeah yeah they never
bring up the thing from so many movies
which is you can't fire a gun in a plane
or it'll like nuts and everything like
set off the air pressure yeah or
whatever so I'm sure we have so much
more to say so let's just dive right
into the trailer let's watch it we'll
stop and go yeah there was like a Golden
Age of the like action movies on planes
there's like this one and like passenger
57 Air Force One already were pausing
executive decision so yeah Air Force One
came out after this was a much bigger
hit at the time yeah you're saying like
what if he went back to tell people as
they're seeing Conair like a movie
critic specifically this film is going
to be absolutely beloved and in a couple
decades this is gonna be one of them the
nineties action movies that everybody
remembers and celebrates like they would
not believe you know it's also like
Nicolas Cage I feel like there there's
key moments in Nicolas Cage
if you went be like this performance is
going to become legendary
yeah it's I'm trying to think of what
the equivalent would be to Dave like
someone that's just so over-the-top and
obnoxious and like right in your face
right now with distance will look back
on and be like that's actually really
fun yeah I don't know that yeah it's
there's your Nic Cage right now you be
the judge anyways keep playing sorry
your summer been requesting this for a
long time and the same derivative this
has the rick roll video
one year after Nick Cage took on the
rock and just three weeks before he take
off a phase I'd like to take his his
face oh wow it's a miracle any of us
survived peak Nic Cage especially Nick
Cage the rock Conair face off is kind of
an unparalleled three movie string what
Orion yeah I don't know what at what
three movies from one actor starring
would be would be a better run like that
kind of right it's just there's such a
specific guy like they feel like
naturally yeah it's a ever do like movie
fights best trilogy I'm just gonna argue
that they are all the same he's playing
different characters but in spirit there
that's the Nicolas Cage action trilogy
because he just brings such a specific
energy which one would you choose a lot
of those three yeah you get to keep one
the other two methods us I mean I think
that of the three Conair goes first for
me and then it comes down to the rock
versus face-off which is very hard I
think I like the action in the rock
better but I think the the cage yeah
in faceoff may be the best ever cage see
I kind of agree with you but for me the
rock is the first off because like the
rock is a good action movie yeah and
like there's some actual genuinely great
performances in it there's plenty other
good movies out there there's nothing
quite like face off I mean face out like
I do think face off maybe overall peak
cage cage one of one yet they
that movie is made of cocaine I know
we're not talking about face-off we did
another one on faceoff but yeah that one
is just like when they when it goes from
the face transplant movie which by the
way Steve Buscemi he wore a face in this
film or allegedly but when they go to
the magnet boot prison right and from
here's what it because it's so the whole
thing is so cartoonish and ridiculous
and yet it's so dramatic it's got that
John Woo where it's like they're taking
it very seriously they're not playing
like this one it's jokey and silly you
know even in the really like dramatic
moments it's kind of silly but not
face-off now speaking of cocaine though
if you had about 65 million dollars to
burn as Nic Cage did after these three
movies
what eccentric purchase would you make
and would it be a dinosaur skull like
Nic Cage but I think I would be that
person who would be buying like what
Nicolas Cage of her movie memorabilia
like he's into like he buys like
spider-man number one and like that kind
of stuff I would be the guy who's like I
want it venkman's original like proton
pack Ghostbusters like that's how they
get me the reason I'll never be Nick
Cage is because I couldn't spend that
much money better than Nic Cage could he
bought dinosaurs and hassles it's true
look it up name names his kids after
superheroes yeah he's living it he's
doing the dream it's alright anyways
keep going
all aboard Con Air and airplane for the
worst criminals some unarmed guards one
undercover agent and an American Hero
with a terrible lawyer admit to you
shall remain no character witnesses no
one in the bar was like yeah the guy had
a knife like nothing yeah I mean it's
it's really not Nicolas Cage's fault at
all and they use that like you were in
the military so you don't ever get to
get away with just defending yourselves
like wait no like you were a green beret
you could kill someone in the street and
we'd be like well the troops
I think that is maybe the 90s or a
different time maybe like yeah but if
you're a green beret you're still
allowed to defend yourself
like you can't be and if I'm sure
there's some some dirt bag costs you
behind the bar and and ends up deadly if
they're gonna assume the best it sounds
like yeah like first offense you'd think
it would speak to his character he's got
this like military curry I don't know it
does seem like he gets really railroaded
really fortunately well fortunately for
us fortunately fortunately for the other
people on Conair as well all right keep
going we'll be here all day
is it really a good ending at the end of
the day cuz if he or not uncon hair I
feel like the well they would have
escaped anyways or maybe it would have
failed because I feel like the end of
culinary's there's a lot of murderers
free in the streets well I think what
would have happened definitely is that
the DEA guy would have gotten his way
and shot the plane down and so we would
have avoided the landing on the strip
probably killing a bunch of gear that
way and like Steve Buscemi is still at
large right yes also garland Greene
would be on still in custody and not out
probably loquacious inclusion in this
movie is leaving everyone baby hell is
alive today because of the the
sacrifices but a lot of babies are
probably dead because of Steve Buscemi
fair enough
anyways keep going plane takes off so
does the action culminating in amazing
set pieces some outlandish comedy and
the world's most high-stakes unboxing
video Panda find some way to work this
heaven in the box
yeah it's cheesy but it has as many
Oscar nominations its verdict oh yeah
tell me which one's better I mean I'd
rather watch it on her an opponent abre
I mean Pope Cameron I mean it has to be
an odd right actually realize until we
were writing this
the first degree and even that past has
a past he passed
and not even that past past can explain
his accent make sure that is better
crime I am however torn apart however
that I won't be there to see this jail
cell had a bullet mark started this day
with birthday try to get what's going on
well I know what's going on because he
it was a Nic Cage note yes character
southern because their quote more
chivalrous and he would you know fat for
the honor of his more than a Yankee
gentleman yeah and you're doing like it
is foghorn leghorn like I feel like that
was what he was working on this voice I
say now I say one minute boy wasn't he
southern knowing like in raising Arizona
right yeah yeah Weiss it's kind of more
like a hillbilly he actually is a good
actor well I guess he can do a voice or
a dialect I believe kind of struggles
with voices he's a great actor but I
feel like a lot of his accent work yeah
he's a little bit also a little too much
it's a little cartoonish in a little
strange and uncanny and it fits the film
you know it's the kind of movie where
it's just like throw anything at the
wall to make it just a little bit more
memorable we were talking I don't think
it got in the trailer but inter notes
there's that shot where so it's a huge
chaotic action scene at the end the
plane is crashing on the Vegas strip
oh the donut yeah and there's a shot
there's there's police cars there's
chases and there's a shot of two cups
and they're on motorcycles and they take
off to go after the plane and Simon West
holds it on the ground as one of them
drops a donut into the foreground and he
just aim like one bite like oh well I
mean this is an unabashedly anti-law
enforcement yes movie which fine but
like that's going so far over the top
like even if the criminals are the
heroes yeah the cops like whoa one donut
I don't
those are those cups aren't characters
we don't ever see them again
and as know it's not a funny scene
actually there's no reason to be there
other than like obviously made Simon
West chuckle and he was like put it in
is he British he's British right so yeah
I mean how do you direct the rickroll if
you're not yeah I feel like he is but I
don't want to say definitely for sure
anyways hold that wait wait when they
call cops in the UK a Bobby Bobby Bobby
drop duster is Jamie biscuit ripping
good laugh yes
he's got a bean like the love child of
Mufasa and Fabio I don't know get a
daughter is sheer awesomeness will
conjure sweet-ass guitar legs out of bit
air
[Applause]
I'm gonna show you God does exist when I
walk into a room some day that boys guy
someday gonna do a posse
they don't do like we were talking
earlier actually right they don't do
rock scores as much anymore no
definitely not like with the prominent
like the guitar lick that comes in every
time like the hero does that like
Michael Bay kind of killed it yeah if
this did come out today like it soon
like I'll show you God does exist let me
like dananananana
Haley it would all be time to be with
whatever song was popular would just be
Suicide Squad yeah pretty much
without superheroes that's what does
kind of rip off a lot of stuff from this
man if only to war like the ragtag
they're criminals but they're the heroes
standing between Poe and his daughter is
a group of dude so bad they've all got
nicknames there's bill that's William
Bedford take a bet and Nathan Jones
diamond dog and come on at least let me
do John Mouse name this is Cyrus Grissom
aka Cyrus the virus shut up John Cusack
stop giving suicide squad ideas it's a
fuzz flip no the man who can climb
anything I don't know if he's changed
his tune recently I think he actually
has but there was definitely a period of
time where Cusack really hated being
asked about canary my kind of refused to
discuss it probably because that was the
only proof he of his like people wanted
to know about yeah aside from like say
anything or something like yeah the
raven wasn't lighting up interview it's
too bad cuz like well and maybe he has
embraced his like inner cheeseball
recently because he's in that like that
like roman centurion like versus Jackie
Chan yeah v and stuff like that no I
feel like he's always that guy who's
like I'm gonna do one being cheesy
Hollywood thing and then I'll make for
indie things that nobody wants to see
but me you know like I'm gonna do my
ultra liberal like war man for man I go
do that
and like then to pay for that I'll do
whatever this unit I feel like does not
hold it holds up as great in some
respects and terrible in others - ility
yeah it's dated now for sure [ __ ] yeah
like back when it was made you could
still just kind of like make a movie
just for the 30-something white dude
yeah he saw and now when you watch it
with me you're like oh this guy is
terrible like the focus of the movie the
movie assumes you're a white dude in
your 30s and that you're relate to him
and if you're anybody else and you watch
the movie like this guy's kind of a dick
to everybody my God he's like cheering
when one of them gets a miscarry yeah
that's part of it and definitely in the
book that's like part of the awareness
that the narrator's maybe not a good guy
so much of is like banking on the cusack
charm that I think maybe decades later
it doesn't exist I got off track is what
I wanted to talk about was Connor -
which is what wait there's not a Connors
well either of a screen writer or the
director I forget which one was talking
about how they want to do Conair - you
psyche refused to talk about and it was
going to be in space and we were really
really dropped the ball as how far from
God's life either treatment or just a
pitch we're just a conscious being on
there to con vacuum shuttle I think on
shuttle and there's a space prison
yeah but enroute is it still like do we
reunite the cast yeah maybe it's the
prison from faceoff and it's like a
unified cinematic universe hmm well you
could even do like the Marvel version of
this or something now that we've got
these whole universes like they're
taking the guys to the shield space
prison in space no one can hear you
rooty reteam yeah done salt cut print
thank you God suicides what ideas your
gum slipknot the man who can climb
anything so
turn to the 90s for a blockbuster that's
top of its class because the cast is
great a it's produced by a be the low
would play we're gonna Dixie and its big
swing in T you don't want the Dan for
realizing you're missing medic week
swing indeed now that's a report card I
Know Why the Caged Bird Sings say
anything B con Malkovich Mission
Impossible rogue nation good cast
yeah wow you can have them do anything
and I'd watch it and any award stealer
for outstanding shorthand and really up
in arms about this still I'm fine tikkun
are earned it it's the voters I blame
please changing a guy from Moby else
pretty yeah yeah no one likes an Cyrus
its coarse rough and it gets it okay
let's roll right in and deleted scenes
poster okay but Conair is so much more
than dealing with all these snakes on a
plane that's complete house until we get
to where we're going
anything yeah cuz he was a stay in the
dog again it's also full of social
commentary like the importance of
respecting women or meditations on
theology there ain't no God
you don't exist de or exploring the idea
that the system makes criminals
what is he one of these sociology majors
and thinks we're responsible for reading
these animals cool cool
okay how about accepting our LGBTQ
friends how does it do when it comes to
racial issues he blew up a meeting of
the National Rifle Association saying
and I quote they represented the basest
negativity of the white race all these
do-rag gotta go homeboy
two-bit negro crackhead well at least
that doesn't go out of its way to
humanize a serial child murderer one
girl I drove through three states
wearing her head as a hat well pause so
I think the reason we didn't put this in
for a couple reasons but it looks like
the movie kind of makes it ambiguous
whether he really is as bad as they
think the whole garland Greene Steve
Buscemi line doesn't actually work at
all and makes me feel like there's a
scene or two missing yes they set up
this idea that first he's crazy like for
most of the movie the joke is
he's like Jeffrey Dahmer Charles Manson
like he's a setup for a joke where it's
like oh he's actually sane right like
that was as far as they found it and
then they have this bit where he gets
off the plane and he meets this little
girl and they have this tea party in
here the tension of it is that you the
viewer are like oh he's gonna murder
this girl like this is what he does he's
crazed me oh we know at least he says
himself that he wore a kid's head as it
drove shots middling child murder he
could have found it somewhere but yeah
and then at the end the plane takes off
and we see the little girl chase after
the play and she's not dead so you go
like oh maybe he's changed his tune but
there was nothing a system works but
they haven't shown us what caused like
there's no indication us that what made
him change his mind he just suddenly
decided to stop murdering kids yeah and
then at the end he gets away
he's like free in Vegas and it's like
played like it's funny like it's a happy
ending but there was that moment where
he decides to stop being a serial killer
fair point also there are
many more racist clips that we left out
but I think overall the issue is like
yeah it's bad but like the movie like
they're supposed to be pieces of [ __ ]
like they're supposed to be prisoners
and [ __ ] and like so calling them
out for being racist like that's prison
well it's it's everybody's racist it's
not just prisoners racist other way it's
like the good guys are also racist
against the prisoner yes like one of
those shots is the guard be like the
do-rags gotta go it's also like
Chappelle's character introduces himself
as a dope feet what people don't do that
they doing these kind of moves nice to
meet you keep going Wow okay well maybe
let's just play some shots of Nic Cage
in slow-mo
[Music]
starry sky high fidelity high velocity
an actual national treasure and we
entering Las Vegas lots of people died
they were demolishing the Oasis or one
of those hotels that crashes into
anyways and they decided they let them
use it it's a control plane demolition
oh it's beautiful in a film like that
comes together mm-hmm Connor I miss this
era of Bruckheimer like Baraka this was
this was dude because it's touched on
but once Bruckheimer started doing the
pirates movies and hooked up with Disney
formally now it's like it's adapt or die
they just don't make movies like this ya
know it's like you know everything's got
more of a family-friendly kind of Sheen
and everything's like two hours and 45
minutes long like I miss the 90s
rough-and-tumble is a good practice
swing for Pirates of the Caribbean like
a roguish hero you know and Orlando
Bloom is clearly the cusack well I mean
what what you can't take I think from
stuff like this that Bruckheimer J
Brooks is carried with him the whole way
is like give people almost too much of a
good thing like don't like a lot of
action movies I think this has become
like a theme of all of these 90s action
movies we've been doing it's like it
used to be you have a big opening action
scene and then something in the middle
and then you have a big action climax
and make speed and this and the rock and
like all of these movies in a row were
like you just make it relentless the
rock is a little there's no point for
that car chase to be as long as it is
once they get to Alcatraz it's basically
just all actually yeah there's just like
every sequence is like another action
thing they have yeah and it just became
this like just movie should just be
relentless non-stop action and that's I
still kind of associate that with like
the high Bruckheimer era mm-hmm which is
great and then like his dark twisted
acolyte Michael Bay like took it I don't
know if he took it too far or just like
it's missing something like there's cuz
the Transformers movies relentless
action and comedy like being shot at
your face and too much of everything I
mean to me that's
a big part of it is that Michael Bay as
far as I can tell has no sense of humor
and I think like it really hurts his
undermines them cuz like he's he's
[ __ ] like pain and gain is really
funny but he doesn't know he has a cruel
sense of humor like his sense of humor
is like bullying bullying spirit yeah
and that's why I like pain and gain
almost like works in spite of itself
like I don't know if he knew that it was
a comedy you know but it's very dancers
on the razor's edge the rock barbequing
a guy's foot like but does he know if
that's funny I don't think he does it's
plaster I know that it's fun
well what else can we say about Conair
it's great you should watch it it's a
lot of things and you haven't seen
Connor what are you doing you stop
immediately go back watch Connor again
we didn't really talk a lot about how
like there's so many great actors just
chewing the scenery adults just every
every actor is at 11 and they're all
crammed on a plane together yeah and I
think more movies need to do this it's
like my second favorite incredibly
over-the-top ridiculous John Malkovich
performance after only rounders only
round or something tops this any KGB is
the greatest ever rounders
I would've owned it next year I'm like
yeah I don't know it's not like one of
the top ones that we haven't done but
it's it's on the list so good I love
anyways I hope you enjoy those tangents
I'm sure we did we'd have more to say if
we had a our other friends who worked on
this with us but just as I'm gonna have
to just live with the two of them sorry
but we'll be back next week where we
will be covering something food because
I was gonna give the clue it's very
obvious I don't know how yeah I'm just
gonna keep my emotion out of it I'm not
gonna get emotional that it makes sense
and we'll see you next week thanks for
watching bye bye
[Music]
you